classification lets us pick one or the
other or some small number of labels for
our data the problem is that real life
doesn't fit into these neat little
categories when we have label data there
isn't yes or no or a B or C or some
labels right then we have what we call a
regression problem we're actually trying
to predict actual outputs right so given
these inputs what's the temperature at
which something will occur or given this
movie on a streaming site and the
attributes and the people that have
watched it what amount of action is it
right because that informs who should
watch that movie there's lots of times
when you don't want to say--but sees
this and isn't this you want to say it's
a little bit of this and a little bit of
this and that's what regression is for
and some of the algorithms we use for
regression are actually quite similar to
classify so for example you can regress
using a support vector machine or
support vector of aggressor right but we
also use other ones like so we're more
likely to use things like linear
regression and things like this so let's
start off with perhaps for simplest form
of regression that's linear regression
right it might not occur to people who
use linear regression for actually what
you're doing is machine learning but you
are let's imagine we have just data
that's got one input so one attribute
attribute one and our output which is
why this is our table of data just like
before and this is our instance data so
we've got one two three four like this
so what we want to do is we want to
input attribute one and we want to
output Y which instead of being a yes or
no is going to be some number on a scale
let's say between Norton one so really
what we're trying to do is we've got our
graph here of our input variable
attribute one and we've got our Y output
and these are our data points in our
training set so here like this and they
sort of go up like this what we're going
to do using linear regression is fit a
line through this data and a line is of
the form y equals MX plus C so in this
case M is going to be the gradient of
our line and C is going to be B
intercept so in this case I guess
something along the lines of this
straight up like this so if our M was
one in this case M equals one or maybe
equals one point two to make it slightly
more interesting and then our C is going
to be let's say C
his naught point naught to these are the
values that we're going to learn using
linear regression so how do we train
something like this what we're going to
do is we want to find the values for our
unknowns which are M and C given a lot
of x and y pairs right so we've got our
x and y pairs here and we want to
predict these values the optimal values
for this data set so we're going to find
values for M and C where this distance
the prediction error is minimized the
better fit this line is the average
prediction error is going to go down if
this line is over here it's going to be
a huge error and so the hope is that if
we predict this correctly and we have an
M and we have a C then when we come up
with a new value that we're trying to
predict we can pass it through this
formula we can multiply it by 1.2 and
then add 0.02 and that will produce our
prediction for y and hopefully that
would be quite close to what it is so
for example let's imagine we have a new
value for attribute 1 let's come in here
we're gonna look up here and this is
going to be the prediction for our Y and
that's the output of our aggressor so
this linear regression is capable of
producing predictions based on its
attribute now if we have more than one
attribute this is called multivariate
linear regression and the principle is
exactly the same is this we're going to
have lots of these multiplier ends we
could say something like Y is m1 x1 plus
m2 x2 and so on for all of our different
attributes so it's going to be a linear
combination a bit like PCA a linear
combination of these different
attributes and it's obviously going to
be multi-dimensional so one interesting
thing about linear regression is but
what it's going to do is predict us a
straight line regardless of how many
dimensions we've got now sometimes if we
want to use this for a classification
purpose we still can all right now I'm
supposed to be talking about regression
not classification but just briefly if
you indulge me we can pass this function
through something called a logistic
function or in the sigmoid curve and we
can squash it into something there's
this shape and now what we're doing is
we're pushing our values up to 1 and
down to 0 right and that is our
classification between 1 and 0 so it is
possible to perform linear regression
using this additional logistic function
to perform classification and this is
called logistic regression I just what I
mention but that's something you will
see
being done on some data so let's talk a
little bit about something more powerful
that's artificial neural networks now
anytime in the media at the moment when
you see the term AI what they're
actually talking about is machine
learning and what they're talking about
is some large neural network now let's
keep it a little bit smaller let's
imagine what we want to do is take item
for attributes and map them to some
prediction some regressed value right
how are we going to do this well what we
can do is we can essentially combine a
lot of different linear regressions
through some nonlinear functions into a
really powerful regression algorithm
right so let's imagine that we have some
data which has got three inputs so we've
got our instances and we've got our
attributes a B and C our inputs are a B
and C and then we have some hidden New
Orleans right and I explained a neuron
in a moment then we have an output value
that we'd like to address this is where
we're trying to predict the value so you
know how much disease does something
have how hot is it these kind of things
depending on our attributes this is
where we put in a this is where we put
in B and this is where we put in C and
then we perform a weighted sum of all of
these things for each of these neurons
so for example this neurons going to
have three inputs from these three here
and this is going to have weight one
this is going to be weight - this is
going to be weight three and we're gonna
do a weighted sum just like in linear
regression so we're going to do weight
one times a plus weight two times B plus
weight three times c add them together
and then we're going to add any bias
that we want to so this is going to be
plus some bias and that's going to give
us a value for this neuron which let's
call it hidden want right because this
is generally speaking we don't look at
these values it's not too important
we're going to do a different sum for
this one so I'm going to all them in
different colors so we don't get
confused so this has got three weights
so this is going to be a different way
this is going to have another different
weight and we're going to do this much
times a Plus this much times B plus this
much times C add them all up add a plus
a bias and we're going to get hidden -
and we're going to do the same thing
with these ones here like this this is
going to be hidden three hidden for
hidden five and so on for as far as we
like to go all right now the nice thing
about this is for each of these can
calculate a different weighted sum now
the problem is that if we just did this
then what happens is we actually get a
series of linear regressions
all right because this is just
multivariate linear regression and in
the end our algorithm doesn't end up any
good right if you combine multiple
linear functions together you just get
one different linear function so we pass
all of these hidden values through a
nonlinear function like a sigmoid or Tan
so a sigmoid goes between naught and 1
so this is not than 1 and a tan
hyperbolic tangent will go between minus
1 and 1 things like this and what that
will do is add a sufficiently complex
function that when we combined them all
together we can actually get quite a
powerful algorithm the way this works is
we put in a B and C we calculate all the
weighted sums through these functions
into our hidden units and then we
calculate another series of weighted
sums so add together to be our final
output and this will be our final output
prediction Y now the way we train this
is we're going to put in lots and lots
of test data where we have the values
for a b c and we know what the output
should have been we go through the
network and then we say well actually we
were a little bit off so can we change
all of these weights so that next time
we're a little bit closer to the correct
answer and let's keep doing this over
and over again in a process called
gradient descent and slowly settle upon
some weights where for the most part
when we put in our a B and C we get what
we want out the other side now it's
unlikely to be perfect but just like
with the other machine learning as we've
talked about we're going to be trying to
make our prediction on our testing set
as good as possible all right so we've
put in a lot of training data and
hopefully when we take this network and
apply it to some new data it also
performs well let's look at an example
we looked at credit checks in the
previous video and we will classify
whether or not someone should be given
credit well something that we cut we
often calculate is credit rating which
is a value from let's say naught to 1 of
how good your credit score is so a could
be how much money you have in your bank
B could be whether you have any loans
and C could be whether you own a car and
obviously there's going to be more of
these because you can't make a decision
on this those three things so what we do
is we get a number of people that we've
already made decisions about right so we
know the person a has a bank account
balance of five thousand two thousand in
loans and he does own a car and he has a
credit rating of 75 or Northpoint 75
whatever your scale is so we put this in
we
sieze wait so but this is the correct
prediction and then hopefully when
another person comes along with a
different set of variables will predict
the right thing for them so you can make
this network as deep or as big as you
want we're typically multi-layer
perceptrons or artificial neural
networks like this won't be very deep
one two three hidden units deep maybe
but what's been shown in the literature
is but actually if you have a sufficient
number of hidden units you can basically
model any function like this right as
long as you've got sufficient training
data to create it so we're going to use
Weka again because Weka has lots of
regression algorithms built-in like
artificial neural networks and linear
regression so let's open up a data set
we're going to use this time so they
said we've got is a data set on
superconductivity right now obviously my
knowledge of physics is should we say
average but a superconductor is
something that when you get it to a
critical temperature it becomes it has
no resistance right which is very useful
for electrical circuits and so this is a
data set about what are the properties
of material and what is the critical
temperature below which it will be a
superconductor now I'm sure there's
going to be some physicists in the
comments that might point out some areas
of what I just said but we'll move on so
we're reading a file this is quite a big
data set so we have a lot of input
attributes and then at the end we have
this critical temperature that we're
trying to predict this temperature if we
look at this histogram goes from 0 to
185 if we look at some of the other
things so for example we've got this
entropy atomic radius which I can
pretend I know what that is which goes
from naught to two point one four is
that good right what we're going to do
is we're going to start by using
multivariate linear regression to try
and predict this critical temperature as
a combination of these input features so
I'm going to go to classify there's just
one classified tab even for regression
we're going to use our same percentage
splitters before so 70% and we're going
to use a simple linear regression
function for this let's go so we've
trained our linear regression and what
we want to do now is work out whether
it's worked or not on our testing set
we've got the variables we wanted Y and
we've got the variables that have been
predicted Y hat and hopefully they're
exactly the same if they're exactly the
same then they're going to be on a
straight line like this so we were
hoping to get a why down here and we
it now of course this won't actually
happened what will happen is these wines
are ever so slightly different than the
Y's we were expecting so you might see a
bit of noise around the center like this
and the way we would normally measure
this is something called mean absolute
error or mean squared error or root mean
squared error which all very similar
ways to measure the same thing it's to
measure what is the average distance
between what we wanted and what we got
so if we were hoping to get away of
North Point - but we actually got a Y of
North Point for then our mistake was we
were not point to too high and so for
every single instance in our test set we
can sum up all of the areas we've got
and we can work out what the average
error was right so we have a hundred in
our test set we sum up the errors and we
divide by a hundred and that tells us I
mean error was a certain amount what
will sometimes happen is your
predictions will be above or below right
and so your actual mean error might be
zero because half a time you predicted
too high half a time you predicted too
low and so on average you've got it
exactly right obviously that's not
correct so what we tend to do is
calculate something called mean absolute
error so essentially if you're too small
we just remove the minus sign and call
call it an error of that amount
all right so if your mean absolute error
is nour point four then what that's
saying is but on average you're naught
point far away live above or below than
where you were hoping to be it's also
quite common to see similar measures
like root mean squared error for every
instance we take our error we square it
we sum them all up and then right at the
end we take a square root right and
again this is a very similar measure to
mean absolute error like the squaring we
move our negative symbols for us it's
also quite common particularly in fields
like biology and medicine to see
something called R squared or the R
squared coefficient and this is
essentially the correlation squared it's
a measure of how well or how tightly
correlated our predictions and our
ground truth were for example this would
be a pretty good correlation if maybe
naught point eight or nor point nine if
these were our points like this and were
absolutely perfect that would be an R
squared of one if our points were
everywhere
that will be an R squared of 0 and what
I saying is it's a value between 0 and 1
that tells
how well we predicted zero means you
basically didn't predict anything at all
it was completely random output one
means you predicted everything exactly
correct now of course that's unlikely to
happen or a test set what you'll find is
you'll hope to get some number but
somewhere around point seven point eight
right but it will depend on how
difficult your problem is to solve so
maybe on a really difficult problem an
r-squared of 0.5 is actually pretty good
right so it's just going to depend on
the situation so we've got our linear
regression trained up
we know that the correlation coefficient
is 0.85 we know that the mean absolute
error for example is 13 degrees what we
haven't done is visualize cyst sometimes
a simplify to do this is just to plot a
scatter plot of what we wanted and what
we actually got from our predictor so
I'm going to right click on linear
regression I'm going to say visualize
classify errors it's going to be a
scatter plot of the expected value and
the prediction we actually got from our
networks so you can see generally
speaking it's not too bad obviously the
data set is quite bunched up in some of
these areas which means that it's
sometimes harder to predict but we've
got a general upward trend which is
exactly what we wanted you can see that
the prediction around zero is not good
at all the x-axis in this instance is
the actual critical temperature of that
particular substance the y-axis is what
the linear regression actually predicted
you can see that the range here is from
about zero to about 136 on our actual
values and the predicted values are from
about minus 30 which doesn't really make
sense to 131 but they're pretty close
most of the ones that caused a problem
with a very low values right because
you've essentially got lots and lots of
values that have a very small critical
temperature on this scale but different
attributes that's been hard to fit a
line to something more powerful
for example a multi-layer perceptron you
know an artificial neural network might
do a better job of those kind of
instances but you can see that there's a
general upward slope in this particular
scatter plot be larger X's represent a
larger error so you can see this is of a
line we're actually trying to fit here
down here with all these small X's and
there's quite a few of them on there so
actually for a lot of these substances
the prediction even by linear regression
has been pretty good regression
algorithms let us predict real scalar
data out of our input variables and then
this can be really useful in a huge
array of different situations where we
want to predict some
it doesn't fit neatly into a yes-or-no
answer or an ABC category label we've
looked at linear regression and
artificial neural networks and obviously
neural networks get pretty deep these
days but these are a great starting
point so thanks very much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this series on data
analysis something a little bit
different from computerphile I wanted to
thank my colleague dr. Mercedes Torres
Torres for helping me design the content
please let us know what you liked what
you didn't like let us know in the
comments what you'd like to see more of
and we'll see you back again next time